[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه الجوله في الصحف
العالميه ونبداها باهم ما جاء في الصحف
الفرنسيه والعربيه والتي تناولت في مجملها
خطاب بوتين الاول اولى هذه الصحفيه صحيفه
تحت عنوان ايضا صراع عالمين وكتبت ايضا عن
الرسائل الضمنيه التي تبادلها الرئيسان من
جهه
الرئيسيه من جهه اخرى الرئيس الامريكي
بايدن وقالت بينما كان فلاديمير بوتين في
موسكو يلوح بالتهديد بسباق تصلح نووي اذا
كما قالت الصحيفه هنا
بتهديد بسباق تسلح نووي رد جو بيضا من
وارسو دعمنا لاوكرانيا لن يتراجع صحيفه
العربي الجديد كتبت هي الاخرى عن هذا
الموضوع ولكن تناولت ما جاء في خطاب وكتبت
حرب مفتوحه ضد الغرب حيث تقول ان رئيس
الروسي كرس في خطابه السنوي لشن حرب
المفتوحه على الغرب مجددا تقديم المباريات
نفسها لغزو اوكرانيا وذلك فيما اعلن
الانسحاب من معاهده نيو سارت وهي اخر
معاهده مراقبه للاسلحه الذريه بين اكبر
دوله او دولتين النوويتين في العالم روسيا
والولايات المتحده الصحيفه البريطانيه
تحدثت هي الاخرى عن نفس الموضوع وكتبت على
لساني رئيس جو بايدن اعتقد اعتقد بوتين ان
الديمقراطيات كانت ناعمه صرخه بيض الحاشده
للحلفاء برساله تضامن وتقول الصحيفه ان
الرئيس الامريكي سال سعى الى رسم صوره
اوسع للمعركه الاساسيه بين الديمقراطيه
والانظمه الاستبداديه وهو موضوع مركزي في
سياسته الخارجيه وقال انها ان معركه
اوكرانيا في طريقها الى الانتصار اذا
مواضيع اخرى تناولتها الصحف العالميه منها
صحيفه
القدس العربي التي نقلت عن واشنطن صعود
اليمين المتطرف اذا صعود المتين المتطرف
في اسرائيل يهدد تحالفها مع الولايات
المتحده وكتبت القدس العربي اذا عن هذا
الموضوع قائله صعود اليمين المتطرف في
اسرائيل يهدد تحالفها مع الولايات المتحده
القوي ودعم الحزبين وهنا في هذا المقال
يقول الكاتب التغيرات الديموغرافيه ادت
منذ الهجره الى دفع السياسه الاسرائيليه
الى اليمين اكثر وجلبت الهجره الجماعيه من
الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق يهودا علمانيين
لهم ميول يمينيه ويفضل يفضلون دعم حزب
الليكود او حزب اسرائيل بيتنا صحيفه الشرق
الاوسط تحدثت هي عن موضوع اخر وهو عن شان
اللبناني وكتبت انفصال الوطني الحر وحزب
الله بات امرا واقعه وتنقل الصحيفه ما صدر
عن مواقف للنائب جبران باسيل الذي هجم
الحزب قبل ايام دون ان يسميه بسبب الخلاف
على دعم الحزب للنائب والحزب حزب الله
النائب السابق سليمان الافرنجيه
وقلبتون تنفيذ اصلاحات لكنهم في الوقت
نفسه يريدون الاتيان برئيس فاسد وردت
مصادر مقربه من حزب الله على هذا الموقف
بالقول ان التيار هو الذي بدا حملته على
الحزب واعتبرت ان اعتبرت ان من الواضح ان
التيار يريد فك التحالف لكنه يرمي الكره
في ملعب
الحزب اذا صحيفه العرب هي الاخرى تحدثت عن
موضوع لكن هذه المره يخص شمال افريقيا
وقالت عوده قطريه الى شمال افريقيا وجبه
مخت لكل بلد وهنا تناولت الصحيفه ايضا
موضوع زياره وزير مساعد وزير الخارجيه
القطري الى تونس والى بلدانك الجزائر
وليبيا وتقول تتحرك قطر في الاشهر الاخيره
لترتيب عودتها الى شمال افريقيا كل بلد
حسب حاجته في ظل المتغيرات التي تشهدها
المنطقه وتسعد دول دوحه لتحقيق تقارب مع
تونس باستغلال حاجتها الى دعم مالي في
الاخير المشاهدين
الصحف العالميه تحدثت ايضا عن عن الثقافه
وهنا صحيفه ليبيراسيون خصصت غلافها
وصفحاتها الداخليه للمخرج الامريكي وقالت
رجل السينما وكتبت عن فيلمه
الذي يسرد فيه سيرته الذاتيه
صغيراته الحانيه تجاه تلك الفتره التي شغف
فيها بالسينما وقرر ان يريد ان او يريد ان
يصبح الرجل سينما ومشاهدينا في الاخير
ننهي بهذا الرسم
الكاريكاتوري الذي يذكرنا بان الحرب في
اوكرانيا اصبحت تشبه متاهه وبهذا الخبر
مشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه هذه الجوله في
الصحف العالميه شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]